today on the matt walsh show what is a
sexy summer camp for children you
probably don't want to know but you're
going to find out today because this is
the sort of thing happening in our
country also with gas prices rising the
left has decided that actually high gas
prices aren't so bad even in fact
americans like paying higher gas prices
we'll talk about that and the senate
unanimously passes the anti-lynching law
every republican signed on to this
pointless bit of virtue signaling the
buy administration commits billions to
spreading gender equity across the globe
and the guy who runs cpac comes out in
support of leah thomas all that and more
today on the matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well we know we all know and you've
experienced this yourself inflation is
out of control and one area where we see
inflation more than ever is in the
grocery store um even though grocery
prices feel like they've doubled good
ranchers prices have stayed low and
affordable so once you subscribe the
price never goes up okay you're getting
locked in you get that stability and
you're getting and you're getting great
prices
and your best price is locked in for
life shop good ranchers for all your
beef chicken and seafood needs good
ranchers only sells 100 american meat
for local farms and ranches they have
signature steak
signature steak burgers and
and plenty of other great items as well
pre-trimmed and pre-marinated chicken
breasts are absolutely delicious and so
easy to prepare the chicken breasts you
know i think deserve an extra mention
here because
chicken breasts in general are very hard
to do right
and because they're one of the most
flavorless kinds of meat you can you can
possibly get they often are very dry and
everything but this chicken bread even
someone who doesn't like chicken breast
i really enjoyed good ranchers of course
all their other
items as well so get your
30 discount on prime steaks and better
than organic chicken today go to
www.goodranchers.com
walsh to save on the quality you've been
looking for good ranchers takes the
guesswork out of the grocery store by
sourcing everything from local farms and
shipping it to your door use my code
walsh to enjoy your box of 100 american
meat and your 30 savings order now to
combat inflation with good ranchers
american meat delivered after years of
complacency ignorance and apathy it
seems that many americans are finally
waking up to the sexual indoctrination
of our children which is happening
everywhere in schools hollywood media
academia corporate america i mean
everywhere there was last year kind of
an awakening about critical race theory
decades after it already infiltrated the
school system unfortunately but there
was an awakening and awakening and now
it seems finally that it is gender
theories turn
just as happened last year with critical
race theory
now we're seeing seemingly every day
new revelations exposing just how
perverse and pervasive this stuff is so
over the last 24 hours um there was
first of all this posted by libs of tick
tock on twitter it says kindercare a
preschool corporation with branches
across america has an extensive lgbtq
curriculum including activities to
explore gender and sexuality this
activity says to switch caps on a marker
to show what you are inside doesn't
always reflect what you are on the
outside
very scientific stuff and then there's a
prompt
for a discussion on all the terms
they're teaching preschoolers about
gender fluidity and non-binary
they learn about gender stereotypes
including that boys can wear dresses and
you should never assume someone's gender
they're teaching preschoolers to become
activists for the lgbtq plus community
they advise teachers to confuse
preschoolers with dolls to show that you
can't make assumptions about gender this
again is for preschoolers in 40 states
but then there's this from the wisconsin
spotlight it says parents
are not entitled to know their kids
gender identity according to a recent
woke training session in the eau claire
area school district empower wisconsin
has obtained a copy of a training slide
from last friday's staff development
session the 2021 2022 equity session on
safe spaces
reminds teachers that parents are not
entitled to know their kids identities
not entitled to let me
pause and back up there a second
parents are not entitled to know
their kids identities
that knowledge must be earned
teachers are often straddling this
complex situation
in uh ecasd our priority is supporting
the students
teachers were encouraged to talk amongst
yourselves
and then it goes on
um
first of all just pausing here parents
aren't entitled to know
this intimate information about their
own children teachers are entitled to
know it parents have to earn the
knowledge
parents must prove themselves worthy
and they do that by demonstrating their
fealty to left-wing ideology that's how
you know if uh if it if you're it's a
safe space or not right that's how you
know if uh a child is going to be in a
safe environment is if the
parent is a leftist and so before they
can
know this information by their child
they have to first prove that they're a
leftist only then can they be entrusted
with the secret knowledge about their
own children but the article has more it
says a district court in 2022 issued a
partial injunction against madison
metropolitan school district's policy
allowing children of any age to
transition to a different identity at
school without parental consent the full
case is now before the wisconsin
wisconsin supreme court the wisconsin
institute for law and liberty and the
alliance defending freedom filed a
lawsuit on behalf of a group of parents
challenging the gender identity policy
that violates the rights of parents to
make important health care decisions on
their children's behalf
this is what the policy that they're
suing about states
these are the provisions
children of any age can transition to a
different gender identity at school
by changing their name and pronouns
without parental notice or consent of
any age
so five-year-olds can do this
district employees are prohibited from
notifying parents without the child's
consent
that their child has or wants to change
gender identity at school or that their
child may be dealing with gender
dysphoria
so
essential information about your child's
mental health will not be shared with
the parents unless the child
has the maturity to realize that oh my
parents should know about my mental
health
district employees are even instructed
to deceive parents by using a child's
legal name and pronouns with family
while using the different name and
pronoun adopted by the child in the
school setting
somehow
though
these two things are not the most
shocking or repulsive news to come out
of the grooming world this week i think
that title belongs to this as reported
by the post-millennial it says a
virtual summer camp aimed at people of
all ages in rural rural appalachia
has been revealed to have taught people
including children about masturbation
gender diversity self-managed abortions
and more over the summer of 2021.
the so-called sexy summer camp put on by
sexy sex ed was held in july and august
of last year on tuesdays and thursdays
sexy sex ed puts on workshops that they
just where they discuss
um
that they say rather quote compels
teenagers and people of all ages to
openly discuss personal and political
consent
sexual safety and anatomy using visual
and performance art open dialogue and
popular education methods
sexy sex ed fills a vital gap in the
reproductive education as a creative
cultural healing solution in rural
appalachia
now uh journalist christopher rouffaux
has pulled some of the screenshots from
this program
including images
of the women who are running this
pedophile workshop you can see the
images there he reports these women are
running a sexy summer camp for children
in rural kentucky with lessons on sex
liberation gender exploration bdsm being
a sex worker self-managed abortions and
sexual activity while using listed and
illicit drugs
the founder is a woman named tanya
turner
and she identifies herself as a femme
fat queer magical pleasure worker
educator and artist
she also self-identifies as a witch
and i have no problem with that
self-identification one of her grooming
comrades is caitlyn cummings
real name as far as i can tell and she
is a radical queer mountain woman is how
she calls herself and then there's
kirsten utten who's a young fat
differently abled community organizer
now interestingly enough when you look
at the pictures of these women
they all look like versions of each
other okay looking at their profiles
it's like looking at one of those faces
of meth progressions
except that the only difference is that
meth addicts tend to be um skinny
so we don't have time to dissect this
aspect of the issue but there does
appear to be something about the pervert
groomer left
that makes everyone look the same i mean
they're indistinguishable
it's as if in their descent into
degeneracy they shed every unique and
appealing characteristic about
themselves turning into a sex-crazed yet
somehow also sexless drone
and you also notice how all of these
women list their fatness
which first of all we can see your
picture you don't need to tell us
second but they they list it like it's a
resume booster
along with their various sexual and
gender identities and so forth
and that's partly because this has
become a substitute for a personality
you know among empty broken people
rather than having a personality they
have labels but it's also because
their membership in various victim
groups is their literal get out of jail
free card allowing them to they hope get
away with being sexual deviants who prey
upon children
um speaking of which one of these
deviants the leader the head witch um
tanya the wicked witch of
petoville
appeared in an instructional video that
that uh
as far as i know is part of this camp
where or at least she's talking about
her own views on things and um she
appears in this video talking about the
wonders of masturbation for children of
all ages
you know like get down with yourself
explore your own body masturbation is
really healthy and i recommend it to
people of all ages
all ages as soon as my nephews could
talk they were doing that that's what
they were doing kids touch themselves
kids start to ask questions and we teach
them the language for their bodies right
that's your nose touch your nose show
aunt t you can touch your nose but my
sister's not saying that when they're
tugging at their penis right
but it feels good right we have to learn
ways to talk to young people about this
so that they know how to explore their
body consensually so that it's not in
public right we don't want people
exploring their bodies in public that's
not consensual
but exploring your body at any age
grandmas grandpas all of us
i don't know why i put my earpiece in to
hear that now before we we analyze what
we just heard there um you should know
that this freak has worked in the school
systems
which will not be a surprise to you
where she admits that uh though her job
was not to teach sex ed she always found
a way anyway listen
the last couple years i worked with the
school systems um and my job definitely
was not to teach sex ed but i uh
explored
constantly and tried to figure out ways
that i could work this in somehow like
i'm in the school systems now i have an
end surely i can figure this out
so now the disturbing thing is is that
we know that sex ed for her um well one
of the disturbing things is if i can
point to just one but uh it does not
mean here's where babies come from it
means talking to kindergarteners about
masturbation
and and note how she claims that people
of all ages masturbate
everyone does it it's normal she says
even toddlers do it now that's not true
of course but
if it was true
if it was something that everyone just
intuitively did at every age
then why do you need to tell people all
the time that they should masturbate
i mean leaving aside how creepy and
gross that is and the fact that this
woman should be in jail i'm saying even
by her own twisted freak logic
why would you need to teach something to
people if you say
they all do it all the time anyway
well the answer is that she simply
enjoys talking to people especially kids
it seems about her sexual habits and her
fantasies
now if she was an old man walking up to
a kid at the bus stop and asking the
child if he masturbates we would label
him a sex predator and we would throw
him in prison
should the response be any different
here of course not
but though this woman has run into
criticism only from people on the right
of course because the left fully
endorses all of this though she's been
criticized and now the people involved
in sexy summer camp are trying to scrub
all evidence of it from the internet uh
putting taking the website down and
everything it's too late though
in spite of criticism she's not gonna be
arrested they will not face any
repercussions aside from angry comments
from one side of the political aisle
which which they can they can write off
and dismiss is simply uh bigotry
and that's because this is not an
anomaly this is not some sort of extreme
outlier
this sort of thing is happening
everywhere it's part of an agenda it's
part of a conspiracy
one that now hopefully finally
we're waking up to now let's get to our
five headlines
[Music]
now as gas prices go up um across the
country
you know the new narrative from the
media and it's not going to get any
better with uh
biden yesterday announcing that now
they're going to ban oil from russia
and they're going to look to make that
up by going to venezuela instead but
that disruption is only going to make
the situation even worse so so biden is
is far from
attempting even incompetently or
ineffectively to solve the problem he's
actually currently in the process of
making it worse
so it's hard to even imagine you can
look at some of the speculation
but it's it's hard to imagine how bad
this is going to get
and we we also know that it's going to
get worse because
a lot of this is is based on
expectation and speculation if biden is
out there when he's asked about this our
gas price is going to go down he said no
they're not going down there it's going
to get worse for a while
that's what he's saying
not exactly imbuing confidence um into
the you know into the marketplace and
for the public
um so what are we gonna do about this
they're they're not gonna bring they're
not gonna do anything to bring gas
prices down they're only gonna make it
worse as we've talked about on this show
they also they consider this a positive
ultimately because it's part of the it's
an opportunity for trans transformation
um
and we i just saw a post on twitter
someone
i think it was one of these dumb
pseudo-celebrities maybe was bette
middle or something but put a you know
had a meme they put out that oh well you
know um wind wind power has gone up by
zero dollars and zero cents
well okay so what am i going to do put a
sale on my car i might turn my car into
a sailboat
maybe stick a you know an umbrella
outside my window or a kite or something
and hope that it pulls me along
um no they consider this an opportunity
and so for them it's not even a problem
and they're not going to do anything to
fix it so
what what's the narrative what's the
approach the approach is to convince us
i mean a quite literal form of
gaslighting the approach now is to
convince us that actually
high gas prices are good and
we like it
we all love when we go to the gas pump
and we see that the dollar those that
dollar amount going up and up and up we
love it we love every second of it uh
here's cnn explaining how just regular
americans are excited for the
opportunity to pay more for gas
here at home at the pump a lot higher
kate but as you mentioned people we've
spoken to over the last couple weeks
they're okay paying higher prices if it
means holding russia accountable for
what they are doing in ukraine but these
prices are likely going to creep higher
kate we'll see how they feel in the next
week or so kate and the big question the
big unknown is do any of these moves
change putin's behavior change the way
he is acting right now what he's doing
right now
uh so yeah regular americans are happy
to pay more for gas if it means holding
putin accountable um
have i like everybody else as a regular
american myself and being around regular
americans just regular people i have not
heard that perspective from anyone
um i have not heard a single person i
think i can guarantee that they did not
talk to a single person this is just
their assumption
um i mean
they're doing this outside of she's got
she's doing this remote outside of a gas
station
but
noticeably
even though she's outside of a gas
station
she's not actually interviewing anyone
to hear them say
so that we can get the example of
someone saying oh yeah as long as we're
holding putin accountable
like that's like that's a thing that a
normal person would say when we're all
sitting around we've all had these
conversations we're sitting around
complaining about the gas prices
have you been there when you're in your
living room you're talking to someone
you're in the break room you say oh man
these gas prices well you know what
i'm okay with it if it means we can hold
putin accountable
that's if someone says that that's
someone who needs some good
old-fashioned bullying
you know someone give him a wedgie a
swirly in the toilet or something that's
that's what that person needs
no that's not any regular person what
any regular person would say
and i have to tell you um i am
not okay
as i've been saying all along i'm i'm
actually not okay
with my family or your family or
anyone's family in america
being forced to make significant
sacrifices in their life
for the sake of ukraine because that's
what this really is okay it's not
holding putin accountable in
general um no it's it's for the sake of
ukraine
nothing against ukraine
nothing in favor of putin
but no one has made an argument
no one has made a compelling coherent
argument
as to why americans should suffer for
the sake of ukraine no one has explained
that to me
all we've heard is this hysterical
nonsense about how this is just like
world war ii and putin is just like
hitler and uh you know he takes over
ukraine next thing you know he's taking
over all of europe next thing you know
he's going to be in france
that's all we've heard and that is that
is hysterical nonsense
i have not heard any sober assessment or
sober analysis explaining why americans
should have to make sacrifices in this
case
and our sacrifices aren't done the
sacrifices that none of us signed up for
are agreed to
sacrifices that by the way
i don't think ukraine would make for the
united states
because this is the position that we're
in as americans all the time where we
we're we're always told that we have to
make these great sacrifices for other
countries
those other countries are not making any
sacrifices willingly for us
when does it ever go the other way
these other countries what do they do
what are they doing for americans like
what do they what sacrifices are
um they making
for the sake of american families well
they're not you can't blame them because
they're focused on their own nations
their own countries their own borders
that's the healthy way to approach it so
they're right
we're not done making sacrifices we just
sent uh
it was agreed that i think it's 16
billion dollars we're going to send over
for ukrainian aid
oh nothing just 16 billion dollars
okay our cities look like third world
countries and refugee camps already
every city you drive through they're
just like it's their tent refugee camps
set up on sidewalks
our border
essentially doesn't exist
so i can think of a lot of ways that we
could use 16 billion dollars but instead
we're going to send ukraine to protect
ukraine's border not ours
again these are sacrifices that we all
have to make they won't tell us why
and we should be happy making them
but you know the rich people media
it's no big deal to them
stephen colbert he's another one had a
very similar take to cnn saying that hey
we should be uh we should be grateful
for making this the sacrifice and paying
a little bit more and besides he doesn't
care doesn't affect him listen i'll tell
you what i will never complain about a
destination wedding again
russia has been hit with a series of
crippling sanctions and it looks like
there's more to come because the u.s and
its european allies are now discussing
banning imports of russian oil take that
putin we're not gonna buy our gas from a
war criminal we're gonna buy it from the
good guys saudi arabia
but
it's gonna cost
since the invasion oil prices have
skyrocketed today the average gas price
in america hit an all-time record high
of over four dollars per gallon okay
that stings but a clean conscience is
worth a buck or two
i'm willing to pay
important right
it's important i'm willing to pay four
dollars a gallon hell i'll pay 15
a gallon because i drive a tesla
right now people all over the world are
trying to find uh inventive ways to help
ordinary ukrainians
yeah we've got to help those ordinary
ukrainians forget about ordinary
americans
the ordinary americans can go to hell
that's the message you can go to hell
it's the ukrainians they're the ones who
matter so our politicians are you know
walking around the capitol with
ukrainian flags on
flying the ukrainian flag
because they're the ones who matter
as for ordinary americans go to hell
just pay more stop whining
your country's being invaded
okay your jobs are being taken away your
sovereignty is being destroyed
your way of life is being annihilated
but uh but you know that that's that's
that's your problem
you know who i hate the most when i
listen that clip it's not stephen
colbert it's like it's the seals in the
audience clapping along
when this multi-millionaire is getting
paid
tens of millions of dollars
yeah he stands up as well for a clean
conscious i'll pay a buck or two
yeah of course you will you know the
thing about stephen colbert he's not
only a millionaire but he's and he has a
tesla as he points out himself
he's not driving around anyway he's got
people driving him he's not even paying
for his own gas
for a clean conscious i'll pay a buck or
two you know i this is something that
shouldn't need to be explained it
doesn't need to be explained to most
people listening to this because if
you're just an ordinary person you know
this but um
a spike in gas prices to this extent
it's not a small inconvenience this is
just like what they told us about
you know it's once again the early days
of covet all over again
it's it's deja vu every day i feel like
i'm reliving that nightmare once again
because it's the mass hysteria people
being tricked into going along with
things that don't make a lot of sense
being being
tricked into or compelled to make quote
sacrifices
for reasons that are unclear and it's
just like that they said oh it's a minor
inconvenience just stay home for a week
or two which turned into a month or two
which turned into a year
you know sacrifice up multiple paychecks
just a small sacrifice
yeah we the people telling you that
because we're in media and government
and everything else in hollywood we're
not making those sacrifices we're still
gonna get paid
and we already get paid more in a month
than you make in a year and we're making
those paychecks but we want you to to
forfeit your paychecks it's a small
inconvenience oh also wear the mask and
have your kids wear it it's a small
inconvenience that's all it is
sure it's it's causing psychological
damage and uh developmental delays
um that
kids may never fully recover from but
it's a small inconvenience
now it's the same thing with gas prices
small inconvenience small sacrifice just
a buck or two he says yeah a buck or two
a gallon steven
and there's more than one gallon you're
putting in your car
that adds up that just they'll just add
up i mean that that very quick that's
not even something that adds up it's
just all at once that is an enormous
pain
that you are inflicting on a lot of
american families
um i've certainly been in places in my
life when um
gas prices go up
if they spike like they are right now i
simply would not have been able to
afford it i just i don't have the money
i would have to i can't get to work
anymore you know you need to spend the
gas money to get to work
but you can't afford to get to work
anymore but if you're not going to work
then you can't afford the gas and it's
this vicious cycle that you're living in
this is a very real thing that millions
of americans right now are experiencing
no it's not worth it for a clean
conscience do you know why
because my conscience
is not at all troubled by anything
that's happening in ukraine i got
nothing to do with it
yeah the fact that we have to get our
oil from places like russia and now
we're just getting it from venezuela
anyway so it's no improvement
that's not ideal but i don't have that
doesn't do anything to my conscience
that was my decision
if it was up to me we'd be
utilizing our own resources
but i'm not the one who made those
choices
here's the last thing i'll say about
this never listen to these people again
when they talk about the minimum wage
and how much they care about raising the
minimum wage so that everyone has a
living wage
that has obviously always just been
a banner you know that's been a bumper
sticker slogan
these people don't give the slightest
damn about working people
because if they care so much about
adding a couple bucks to the minimum
wage even though the vast majority of
american workers are not minimum wage
workers
you know this is something that you're
doing for teenagers who are living at
home those are the people making minimum
wage especially the ones that are making
minimum you know
there there are not very many
working adults
who are making minimum wage
um for any extended period of time
so that's what we have to do for working
people is raising minimum wage which
will only help if it helps anyone at all
and ultimately it doesn't even help the
people it's supposed to help because
they're going to get fired and replaced
by you know the automated machines and
mcdonald's and all that kind of stuff
but if it helps anyone at all it's a
small sliver uh gas prices though
that is a
significant suffering you're inflicting
on all working people and they don't
care about that
all right this is from npr the senate
once again showing how much they care
about people unanimously passed a bill
on monday that criminalizes lynching and
makes it
i can't i can't even get past the first
sentence from npr
a bill that criminalizes
lynching
and makes it punishable after by up to
30 years in prison
what so that's what it is now before it
was we're making it a hate crime
now it crim so it wasn't a crime before
it's not even that it wasn't a hate
crime before that was what they
originally thought now they're telling
us that they had to pass the bill
because it wasn't even a crime did you
know that before they passed this bill
you could just go out and lynch anybody
and they
the cops would walk by and say oh you
just lynched someone okay
that apparently it was it was not a
crime
um the bill sailed through the house of
representatives last month and president
biden is expected to sign it while eased
through both chambers of congress this
time with virtually no opposition the
path to passage took more than 100 years
and 200 failed attempts
senator tim scott republican
was very excited about this and wanted
to take credit for he said tonight the
senate passed my anti-lynching
legislation taking a necessary and long
overdue step toward a more unified and
just america after working on this issue
for years i'm glad to have partnered
with colleagues on both sides of the
aisle to finally get this done
you know there are plenty of um
conservatives you hear from who for some
reason want tim scott
they see him as the future of the
republican party they want him to run in
2024.
tim scott is the is
the definition
of a just
of a
milk toast establishment republican
and it's not any different oh but he's
black though so we run him right and
then we'll outsmart the left and and
they won't be able to criticize him
because we know how well that worked
with clarence thomas
but you'll go check in with uh candace
owens and find out how much your skin
color covers you from the left
criticizing you
but tim scott i mean there's no reason
to single him out i singled him out
because he singled himself out and took
credit for this ridiculous empty
pointless virtue signaling that they're
engaging in when there are real problems
in the world and americans are actually
suffering and they're not suffering from
being lynched because nobody's been
lynched in this country for 40 years and
even when they were lynched it was
already a crime multiple times over
but this is what they're uh this is what
they're they're focusing on and every
republican in the senate voted for it
you know every single one they're
between the house and the senate there
were three republicans thomas massey
being one of them
um
who who said we're not going to go along
with this and he explained his reasons
which is is that the bill is totally
unnecessary it is already a crime
to lynch people you're already going to
prison potentially worse than that
if anything the irony is with this
because they're saying that it's up to
30 years in prison
well prior to this
if you actually lynched someone you are
guaranteed to
life in prison at a minimum
that's premeditated first-degree murder
so this if any if this accomplishes
anything if it changes the way
that lynching is handled by the courts
it just makes the penalty lighter than
it was before
um
[Music]
so
that's one reason not to support it
totally unnecessary lynching is already
a crime
and if you're lynching someone as i
pointed out last week if you're lynching
someone which no one has done in 40
years but if you're the first person in
40 years to do this then and you're
lynching someone for racial reasons
which is what this is really focused on
you have committed first-degree murder
so you're going to jail for the rest of
your life for that and that's already a
hate crime
so this bill does not change a damn
thing
the only reason why this bill was
written in the first place and pushed
through
is again empty pointless virtue
signaling because this is what the
people in charge of our country are
interested in right now
and also just to help enforce the
narrative
that uh we are a systemically racist
country because when people hear about
the anti-lynching law the the stupid
people out there you know the kinds of
people by the way who hear about the
so-called don't say gay bill
and say oh so you mean that in florida
you
if you say the word gay the alarms are
going to go off and there's going to be
you know
cops are going to rappel down from
helicopters and execute you on the spot
and throw you into a fire
the same people who buy that we think
that it's actually illegal now in this
whole state of florida to say the word
gay are the same ones who when they hear
about this legislation
they say oh my gosh
so it was legal to lynch people this
whole time
and if we needed this bill so much that
that must mean that people were getting
lynched all the time
i've never seen it myself ever or heard
of such a thing ever but it must be
happening
so that's what it was meant to do
virtue signaling and
a narrative of systemic racism and every
republican in the senate went along with
it
that's cowardice here's courage um from
the daily wire jk rowling slammed a new
transgender bill that would lower the
age at which a person can legally change
their gender to um from 18 to 16 a move
that she said will hurt the most
vulnerable women in our society the
first minister of scotland nicola
sturgeon introduced a gender recognition
reform bill
that allows a trans person to legally
change their gender and receive a new
birth certificate with their gender on
it through easier means than before
um
the author said the law nicola
sturgeon's trying to pass in scotland
will harm the most vulnerable women in
society though seeking help after male
violence rape and incarcerated women
statistics show that imprisoned women
are already far more likely to have been
previously abused
rawling followed up her post
noting that multiple women's groups have
presented well-sourced evidence to
nicola sturgeon's government about the
likely negative consequences of this
legislation for women and girls
especially the most vulnerable and as we
know jk rowling has been on this sort of
crusade and i say that in in the most
positive way possible
um
for a long time and as she was going
back and forth about this on twitter
so someone hit her with the thing that
i'm very familiar with which is uh the
old are you sure you want to die on this
hill
and
a woman by the name of wanda said to jk
rowling you really want your legacy to
die on this hill jk rowling and rowling
responded yes sweetheart i'm staying
right here on this hill defending the
right of women and girls to talk about
themselves their bodies and their lives
in any way they damn well please you
worry about your legacy i'll worry about
mine
um
i mean this this is real courage from
from jk rowling and i'll always give her
credit for it even though if she were
ever made aware of who i am she would
probably hate my guts and disagree with
everything that i say except on the
topic of gender and even on the topic of
gender she'd probably disagree with most
of what i say because she's not even
taking the position that transgenderism
itself is uh is sort of like incoherent
at least she's not openly taking that
position she's taking a much more
minimalist approach to this and really
focusing on the ways that you know women
the
children are indoctrinated into it uh
you know the way women's sports teams
are being invaded locker rooms and
prisons and that sort of thing
but even that minimalist
approach this issue will still put you
in line for an unimaginable
avalanche of hatred and outrage
especially if you're someone like jk
rowling as famous as she is
and famous not um in you know
conservative media but famous
mainstream
having cultivated this fan base um many
of whom you know are leftists
and she has chosen just because she
believes in this issue she has chosen to
yeah she's got a billion dollars but
she's chosen to do something that's
going to alienate many of her fans it's
going to hurt her career prospects going
forward and it's going to detract from
her bottom line and i guarantee it
already has
um and even if you have a billion
dollars i mean even if you have money in
power we've seen that it takes courage
to do that and that is courage that
almost no one in our culture has
to do something
because it's the right thing
knowing that you will not benefit from
it in any way
you're not going to benefit financially
you're not going to benefit with more
fame i mean jk rowling can't get more
famous than she already was
you're not going to benefit by all the
applause and adulation you receive
because instead you're going to be
mocked and jeered
almost no one has the courage for that
jk rowling on this issue has
vastly more courage than
almost every elected republican
in the country and almost every
prominent conservative in the country as
well
more courage even than the guy who runs
cpac and we'll talk about that in the
daily cancellation come on up in a
minute um
okay what else do we got here
so
uh from the daily wire it says more than
100 million u.s tax
households or 61 of all american
taxpayers paid no federal income taxes
in 2021 according to a report from the
tax policy center one republican senator
says that's simply not okay demanding
that all americans should have some skin
in the game senator rick scott of
florida unlike most members of gop has
no problem urging tax increases last
month the center unveiled a plan
that said all americans should pay some
income tax to have skin in the game even
if a small amount currently over half of
americans pay no income tax
um and so he's actually trying to raise
the income tax rate
um so that everyone at least is or not
even really raise the rate but
increase the number of people who are
paying income tax
and
here's the way i look at that because we
are it is important to point this out
because we're always told how you know
the rich people aren't paying their fair
share and everything but when it comes
to the income tax in fact the rich
people are paying almost everything okay
they're paying almost everything and
you've got a huge swath of the american
public that pays no federal income tax
at all
now
i'm in favor
so this is kind of an awkward
issue for me because
i you know i have two views on this that
may seem to be intention but i think
actually they're not
i'm in favor of
abolishing the irs i can't imagine how
anyone could not be in favor of that
get rid of the income tax
and then we can focus on you know
consumption taxes other kinds of taxes
to not make up for all of the income tax
that's being taken away
because the government already brings in
you know three to four trillion dollars
and they waste a huge amount of it
so they're bringing in way too much
money as it is
i'm in favor of getting rid of the
income tax
i think ideally you know in the perfect
world you get rid of the income tax and
you replace it with nothing
so that's a 40 or so of the government's
income that you're taking away
and saying now make do with the 60
which which means you still have you
know trillions to to
play around with and to waste
so that ultimately is what i'd like to
say i'm against the the federal income
tax completely i'm against income taxes
in general i mean i have a philosophical
problem with the idea that the
government can just
take its a portion of your income can
come in and with the withholding system
that they can come in and take it
before you even get your hands on it so
they take what they want of your income
and then give you the remainder and if
they take too much then they hold on to
it for a year and give you back the the
the extra without any interest at all
i've got a big problem with that
but
if we're going to have the income tax
um
then
everyone should be taking part in it if
we're going to have it then there should
be some real equality here
kind of the way i feel about hate crime
laws i don't think hate crime laws
should exist
i don't think that should be a category
that exists but if you're going to have
them then they should be applied equally
so i'd say the same thing with uh hate
crimes finally
uh important story here that i've had
haven't had a chance to mention from a
variety says harvey weinstein was caught
with contraband milk duds in november
prompting a reprimand from la county
jail guards according to records viewed
by variety the milk duds were found
during a search on november 10th after
weinstein had a face-to-face meeting
with one of his attorneys and apparently
they uh
they smuggled into milk duds and
weinstein had to apologize officially to
the court he said this was an innocent
misunderstanding will not happen again
i've been a model inmate following the
rules and regulations and i'm sincerely
sorry
the only reason that i'm bringing this
up
wait why am i bringing this up i have no
idea well because why like taking that
risk from milk duds that's my only
problem here
there are a selection of candies that i
would
try to sneak into prison as contraband
risking my freedom for
um
milk duds don't make the list
that list is mike and ikes snickers
gourmet jelly beans not the big ones
okay
but the the small gourmet ones um milky
way bar i'll throw in a twix that's what
i'm risking my freedom milk duds
repulsive
and shameful harvey weinstein you should
be ashamed for a lot of reasons but you
know that is certainly among them let's
get now to the comment section
[Music]
okay dailywire.com
sweet baby comments
we're gonna try this
i don't know why um
let's go to clip 10.
hey matt my name's jonah i'm the
co-creator of the honorary mention spg
and familiar playing in the background
i come bearing a very important message
from delegates of the sweet baby gang
hi not jen ledger here it's your boy
asian glow aka sweet baby glow my name
is zangtar queen of the moon my name is
amanda and my preferred pronouns are
texan
and sometimes pirate my preferred crowns
are we and shopping bags my preferred
pronouns are
and a long awkward silence no less than
four seconds long
now i have one question for you sweet
daddy boss when are you joining the
sweet baby gang facebook group why
haven't you joined the facebook group
yeah daddy we're waiting for you your
sweet babies need you and you're just
letting us down i'm cordially inviting
you to join the loyalists of your sweet
babies
what are you waiting for come on man
you have like one week and then i'm done
with it and all of my shopping carts are
going directly in the middle of the
driving lane until then we'll be
crawling aimlessly through the metaverse
[Music]
also
give me credit here you can see how hard
i'm trying to grow a beard and it's not
working out well
but that's my dedication so
it's your turn to step up dirty i'm
hudson little admin of the sweet baby
gang facebook chapter
and i approve this message
um
so what's happened here basically is
that
the video comments have become really
nothing more than a forum for my own
listeners to troll me
and i feel deeply betrayed
i find it offensive first of all because
you know that i am not
i'm opposed to trolling trolling is
something that i would i would never do
i oppose it in principle
and frankly i thought that when we
started doing the video comment feature
all of you guys would would send in
really intelligent videos where you're
sitting in like fancy chairs smoking a
pipe and pontificating eloquently about
you know like quantum physics or
whatever
i thought this would class the show up
that was the idea
i can't make the show any smarter
because i'm stupid so what i need is
other people to have really smart
content that i could just put into the
show
um
make us all seem smarter and elevate the
entire experience and instead it's
turned into this
yeah nice editing though on that video
i'll give them that um and
no i'm not gonna join the facebook group
i'm sorry to say i didn't even know that
i had a facebook group
but i appreciate that i have it and
thank you so much for that comment
you're all banned from the show um
captain criticized says matt i have to
correct you there is in fact another
type of body shaming that is even more
prevalent and permissible in our society
than fin shaming shaming men's height is
widely known in exercise especially by
fat women who really don't have any room
to talk probably because they take up
all the room um
i don't know
again you know just like trolling any
kind of jokes about weight and inside i
don't we don't do that on this show so
how dare you but well you're you're
right though actually um you actually
raised a good point because that is that
is true and that's why we know all the
talk about body shaming and everything
it is uh it's all completely empty
because
that is one form of actual body shaming
that people do
all the time and uh there's not a lot of
it doesn't get a lot of press nobody's
worried about it there's a few reasons
for that but one of them is that again
the the body positivity antibody shaming
stuff is is always focused on women and
so
you know women might get made fun of a
little bit for being short but that's
not nearly as common women in general
are shorter and you could be a woman on
the shorter side and it's not really
going to cause a lot of problems for you
but as a man you know it creates it
could create some serious problems
um
one of the problems being as much as we
were told yesterday by the woman that we
played in the daily cancellation that
you know women are much more enlightened
in their sexual attraction well a lot of
women they're not gonna go for a shorter
guy you know um
so
that's why i don't think it gets the
same amount of presses because it's
something that's something that affects
men and this is this only goes around
women because also the other thing that
we're told is like well only women are
ever body shaped men don't have to deal
with that which of course is completely
completely ridiculous
um
don lee says thank you matt walsh for
singing for not singing imagine today
like michael and ben spg for life
is that
they both saying imagine is that what is
that what actually happened
is this a joke
i would have thought it was a joke
except there was a there was another
comment that mentioned this occurrence
as well
and i don't know what happened i'm out
of the state right now i leave the state
and this is what and ever and all hell
breaks loose
if so uh then
needless to say um they're both banned
from
from the daily wire ben shapiro is fired
because i have that authority
all right we have just a little over 24
hours
until we get to the premiere of our next
big hit the hyperions the film is
exactly what entertainment and hollywood
is missing these days it's not woke at a
zero agenda and it couldn't care less
about your pronouns or your politics
because when it comes to entertainment
it's just about having fun and that's
what this movie is you can see it for
yourself uh check out the trailer good
day hyperion club members
[Applause]
we've come for one thing
our titan badges this titan badge can
grant an individual superhuman power
perhaps it's time for someone else to
take on the responsibility
on my way
[Music]
[Applause]
she's trying to destroy me
thy appearance is a dysfunctional family
film with throwback vibes and it's 100
worth the stream we'll be streaming the
film once on march 10th for all of
youtube if you want to get any movie or
any of our content after that you got to
become a daily wire subscriber so head
to dailywire.com subscribe so you don't
miss out on any more of our content
going forward now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
so
matt schlapp is an influential
and powerful figure in conservative
politics he's the chair of the american
conservative union which organizes and
hosts cpac each year cpac of course is
the largest annual gathering of
conservatives
um
what are the conservatives
at cpac or running cpac trying to
conserve though i mean that's always the
question that we we face as
conservatives
uh and i know how i answer it but i'm
wondering about matt's answer today
after this tweet from from him from the
head of cpac referring to leah thomas
the the male swimmer who competes
against women schlapp said no matter
what one thinks of leah's ability to
swim with women her story deserves our
compassion it will be interesting to
hear leah's point of view in 30 years
now schlapp continued a little bit later
in response to criticism from another
conservative named jenna ellis schlapp
said
jenna all i'm saying is is in the end
trans people deserve our love and
compassion we should defend girl sports
against competing with men aggressively
but in the end remember that all people
deserve respect kind of simple if
showing decency makes you boycott cpac
i'm good with it but a few minutes later
he followed up and said jenna this is a
fake or a false controversy you're upset
with cpac because we didn't invite you
to speak
we score the bills aimed at protecting
girl sports and our kids from gender
confusion indoctrination i don't wish to
normalize it but simply just deal with
it with compassion
okay so there are a few different things
going on here all of them embarrassing
for match lap the first is that he's
resorting to the classic tactic of weak
minds by refusing to engage the
criticism and instead impugning the
motives of the person who is making the
criticism now i don't know if jenna is
upset that she wasn't invited to cpac
but whether she is or isn't that is
little bearing on the conversation and
schlapp also hammers this point about
compassion
this is the shield
that people hide behind to excuse their
apathy and their acquiescence
trans people deserve love and compassion
he says well
yes they deserve love and compassion to
the same degree that we as christians
are called to have love and compassion
for everyone that's not news
nobody's saying otherwise by repeating
this talking point schlapp is implicitly
advancing the leftist narrative that
criticism of the trans agenda is born
out of hatred towards trans people
personally it's about on level with
saying that you know you must hate black
people if you criticize blm this is what
we're getting from the guy who runs cpac
and how do we how do we how do we show
love and compassion to trans people or
to anyone else
do we express love and compassion by
cooperating with delusion by
surrendering to lies by agreeing with
falsehoods
no there's no love or compassion absent
of truth
there's no love or compassion absolute
truth there's also no love or compassion
absent of justice and fairness
the truth is that leah thomas is a man
that's the truth the other truth is that
he is knowingly putting his own desires
ahead of the rights of the girls that he
is exploiting
um he's he's also exposing himself to
them in the locker room knowing that
they're uncomfortable with it
justice demands
that we condemn sick and perverse
behavior like that
a man who walks into a woman's locker
room and disrobes
that behavior should be condemned
justice which is both loving and
compassionate calls us to defend
the girls against thomas not thomas
against the girls
and what about the girls who are the
actual victims here schlapp chose to
focus on the dudes stealing the medals
and trophies
and sexually harassing them in the
locker room rather than focus on the
women he's victimizing
he cries for compassion for one ignoring
the other and actually it's worse than
that because he didn't say that leah
thomas himself deserves compassion he
said that his his story or rather her
story as he put it deserves compassion
the story of leah thomas is what leah
thomas
is doing right it's his actions his
behavior that's the story
i'm not exactly sure how one can have
compassion for a story
but i assume that it means being
understanding you know tolerant
accepting
i am none of those things when it comes
to leah thomas's behavior far from
understanding or tolerant we ought to be
angry
that's the appropriate and morally
healthy response to selfish deranged
destructive behavior you know we hear a
lot about how uh there's so much anger
in the country today and people are too
angry with stopping angry
i think i think our problem is is you
know really almost precisely the
opposite of that
there should be a lot more anger than
there is most of what what we call anger
is performative it's not actually real
and there are a lot of people pretending
to be angry about things that they're
not really angry about there are people
who are uh who notice things that ought
to make them angry and they pretend to
be angry but they aren't really
and you know that based on how what
they're saying and how they're engaging
with it and how quickly they move on
from these things
you should the story of someone like
leah thomas
should instinctively
fill you with anger towards him
that should be your intuitive response
and if if it's not then there's a deeper
problem going on within you
but the misappropriation of the word
compassion is not the biggest problem
here the biggest problem and the thing
that schlapp tried to paper over in his
follow-up tweets is that he referred to
thomas a male as her
this to me is the unforgivable sin
because as soon as you start playing the
preferred pronoun game you've forfeited
reality you've surrendered
you've raised the white flag
you've given up everything
that's not an exaggeration
if in submission to the left you're
going to refer to men as women and women
as men then what else is there to argue
about
are you going to draw the lines
somewhere else after you've already
abandoned objective reality where will
that line be
and and where are you going to draw it
you can't draw it in reality you've
already given up on that
not only is the pronoun thing a hill
worth dying on as uh
jk rowling says
there's there's rarely been a hill more
worth dying on
you know many conservatives now schlapp
included
have run screaming from this hill
dropping their swords and their banners
and fleeing off into the forest only
later find some smaller little mound in
the shadow of the big hill where they
can pretend to make their principled
stand but it's too late for that because
you've surrendered objective truth
there's nothing else
now schlapp in damage control mode has
tried to tr backtrack from
most of this the daily wire reports
quote in a tuesday afternoon statement
schlatt promised that cpac believes in
fiercely defending girls and women's
sports at every level including in state
legislative chambers the left's war on
gender must be confronted and cpac will
continue doing just that the statement
said and we will continue to demonstrate
decency to all those involved
his use of the pronoun her was quote not
an intentional statement one way or
another schlapp said in a late afternoon
fund interview with daily wire i was
just quickly responding in a tweet he
said
not an intentional statement
but you wrote it
did you write it by accident was the cat
walking across your keyboard
actually the the unintentional excuse
makes it worse
because if schlapp is at the point of of
you know where he where he unconscious
unconsciously calls men her
if that's where he's at now
then he's even farther gone than it
first appeared
he's been conditioned he's been
brainwashed
it is a very unnatural and awkward thing
to use the word her when referring to a
dude
a person may get to the point where they
utilize the preferred pronoun without
thinking about it but that means that
they've been totally conditioned by the
left their natural reflexes have been
rewired
now is that what
is happening here or was he making the
deliberate and conscious choice
to use language that affirms left-wing
gender ideology
either way it's bad
and either way we must say that matt
schlapp is today canceled and we'll
leave it there thanks for watching
thanks for listening have a great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pavo valdoski
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
22.
john vickley here daily wire editor in
chief wake up every morning with our
show morning wire where we bring you all
the news that you need to know in 15
minutes or less
join me and my co-host georgia hal for
daily coverage of all the biggest
stories on morning wire